prendre son temps relax et festoyer des
mots très souvent associées à l'alcool
le canada donne une culture du temps
d'arrêt lié à la consommation d'alcool
sa marque étendard est donc la
différence entre le jour et le soir
entre le travail et la fin de semaine
entre une journée ordinaire et une
journée où il ya un événement
particulier
l'alcool est partout à la télé dans les
publicités les émissions ainsi que dans
les grands événements culturels et
sportifs
l'alcool c'est festif saada à discuter
davantage que les miens dompter dans le
milieu d'affaires souvent vent à toute
sorte et qu'on va voir comment savoir
les durant le mois de février
c'est joli l'alcool est tellement
présent que chaque mois de février ils
sont nombreux comme francis isabelle
claudia et offrir aux attentes et de ne
pas en france c'est bon même sans alcool
en mairie
ouais même sans alcool romance je suis
une pleureuse social mais c'est quand on
fait le diffuse un tuyau qu'on réalise
qu'on ait notre vie est vraiment sociale
président d'éduc'alcool louise nadeau et
professeur en psychologie et chercheuse
en toxicomanie à l'université de mourir
on est une culture où boire est un
facteur d'intégration sociale et quand
les gens ne boivent pas on le voit comme
un rejet et jean ont pas débattre du
fait qu'on décide de world pas boire
d'alcool t on disait à beslon titre
enfin tous les trucs comme ça mais
souvent les gens ils posent des
questions parce que tu décides de
pomerol
catherine paradis est analyste principal
du centre canadien sur les dépendances
et l' usage de substances
l'an dernier on a mené la deuxième étude
sur les coûts sociaux liés à l'usagé de
substances au canada l'organisme évalue
à plus de 14 milliards de dollars au
canada
les coûts reliés à la consommation
d'alcool en soins de santé justice
pénale et perte de productivité
c'est plus que le tabac le cannabis et
les opioïdes
mais l'impact le plus important est sur
notre santé oms a classé l'alcool comme
cancérigène on sait maintenant que
l'alcool causent ces types de cancer
dont on parle pas juste une association
mon talent d'une causalité ici leurs
plus hauts bois plus nos risques de
cancer augmente et bien sûr les cancers
de l'appareil digestif sont les plus à
risque
le centre canadien sur les dépendances a
élaboré une directive de consommation
d'alcool en fonction de la probabilité
de développer certaines maladies vers le
risque
de décès prématurés liés au cancer du
sein augmente de 13 pour ça mais là faut
bien comprendre le sait pas on est à 0
je prends un verger 13 % de chances de
développer un cancer du sein puis à deux
vaches de 27% l'on parle ici de risque
relatifs en effet une femme sur 45 va
mourir du cancer du sein
si vous buvez deux verres par jour vous
augmentez vos risques de 27% des trous
cette femme c'est sûr que des
vulnérabilités génétique qui font en
sorte que c'est peut-être trop pour une
personne c'est dans ma famille ma grand
mère ma mère mes tantes sont toutes
décédées du cancer du sein
c'est évident sachant que l'alcool est
un cancérigène notamment sociaux cancer
du sein du sein c'est évident que dans
un tel cas deux fois par jour c'est trop
pour moi qui savent pas encore c'est
qu'il faut respecter les limites
quotidienne même si on n'a pas dû de la
semaine
la recommandation qu'on fait
actuellement de 3 consommation pour les
hommes que pour les femmes ça vient d'où
s'est basé sur quoi on a analysé toutes
les données scientifiques qu'on avait
par rapport à la mortalité et la
morbidité associée à certaines maladies
chroniques qui on sait sont liés à la
consommation d'alcool
donc on analysait toutes ces données là
et on a tenté d'établir le seuil où les
méfaits y les bénéfices s'annulent
on a l'impression certaines personnes
vont dire aussi que le fameux trois
consommations de consommation ça ça
faisait que ça nous encourage presque
encore ça mais trois il faut faire
attention à ce que les normes dit c'est
pas vous devriez en consommer trois par
jour c'est si vous en consommez vous ne
devriez jamais en consommer plus de
trois fois par un plus plus de trois par
jour
[Musique]
il ya une hausse
marc et des décès et des
hospitalisations liées à l'alcool chez
les femmes depuis quelques années et
quand on regarde pour le québec
spécifiquement c'est au québec que les
jeunes femmes rapporte le plus consommé
de manière excessive c'est à dire au
moins quatre consommation plus d'une
fois par mois
et tous ces publicités qui invite les
femmes sous le prétexte de l'égalité des
genres à consommer autant que les hommes
une femme ne peut pas consommer autant
qu'un homme c'est pas sexy ce c'est
biologique légalité des gens ça passe
pas par le même nombre de shoots eurent
pris dans une soirée le khlifi peu plus
que deux vallées vega 3ème des grandes
choses qu'on n'oublie c'est le verre
standard mais le verse tendance est pour
beaucoup plus par exemple un verre de
bière ses 340 millilitres et un verre de
vin c'est 140 mellick
on s'est rendu compte que quand on est à
la maison nos verres standards sont
beaucoup plus importants il ya certains
bénéfices
notamment pour certaines maladies
cardiovasculaires mais ça c'est chez des
adultes de 40 ans et plus
pour les hommes et pour les femmes boire
un verre par jour réduit les risques
d'avc mortels mais le même verre
augmente aussi les risques de cirrhose
du foie
les conséquences liés à la
surconsommation ne se limite pas aux
maladies chroniques
quand on au but 4-5 consommation en une
heure on est plus à risque d'avoir des
comportements violents de conduire avec
facultés affaiblies et d'avoir des
accidents passe nos réflexes son polo de
faire des cheveux le tiers des
commotions cérébrales au canada sont
liés à la consommation d'alcool est ce
que c'est la prochaine grosse bataille à
faire la santé publique notre
consommation d'alcool c'est que si nos
gouvernements nos ministères nos
organismes réglementaires décidé dans
une perspective de biens communs de
s'attaquer à l'alcool il est évident que
sur le plan scientifique en or des
données robuste beaucoup de données au
but ce qui justifierait des amendements
et des modifications des règlements et
de nos lois liées à l'alcool pur non
participants le mois sans alcool aura
été révélateur des huit semaines comme
ça tout le temps si c'est vraiment
vraiment spéciale anti commence à
réaliser les effets que sanaa sur ton
corps sur la ligne aussi parce qu'elle a
tellement calories par l'alcool c'est là
où tu vois qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'occasions d'en prendre
puis dans un défilé 7,7 fait réaliser
succès présent à la société quand même
je me suis concentré beaucoup plus ce
sont les gens avec qui j'étais que sur
qu'est-ce que je buvais dans le vent
face à nous
après une pause de la couronne me
prendre une pause dans notre vie de
réaliser notre notre relation à l'alcool
d'une relation avec avec l'alcool la
relation avec nos frères et l'album